in the early 1900s Carl liner did
something very bold he mixed his own
blood with his colleagues to address an
experimental
question why is it that sometimes blood
clots when mixed with others but not all
the time so he got samples of blood
cells and blood serum from himself and
apparently healthy men in his lab and
looked for patterns when it clotted he
marked it with a plus and lo and behold
there were patterns
and he could assign each individual to
one of three groups based on the
reactions these were labeled as a b and
c liner himself falling into category C
which was later renamed as
o we now know why these patterns were
observed different groups had different
people which have different types of red
blood cells and different antibodies
that react towards different foreign red
blood cells this information has been
imperative for developing safe blood
transfusions and led landsteiner to be
awarded the Nobel Prize in physiology or
medicine in
1930 the discovery of the blood
group system is now considered one of
the most important discoveries in the
history of medicine as I've been reading
more about blood its importance and
links with longevity along with the
blood system it got me thinking does
blood group have an impact for health
well before we get that we first need to
address what is the molecular
underpinnings of the blood
groups well the blood system is
sugar based attached to the lipid
membrane of the red blood cells are
different sugars a blood type have
socalled glycolipids with the final
sugar being netal
galactosamine B blood groups have
instead D galactose and type O blood
have nether just the shter sugar chain
although these differences are in sugars
the proteins responsible for making
these sugar chains are encoded within
our DNA sequence which explains why we
inherit our blood type the gene codes
for three main alyss a b and you guess
that O A and B versions of the gene
encode slightly different glycos
transferases that are the enzymes
responsible for adding either Nile
galactosamine or for B de galactose
while the gene version for O blood types
has a frame shift mutation which
essentially means a non-functional
enzyme is made so neither sugar is added
to the
chain Now by sticking out of the surface
of the cell these glycolipids these
sugar chains attached to the cell
membrane are targets for
antibodies if a different type of blood
cell is detected than expected it
triggers the immune response antibodies
help our bodies to distinguish self from
nonself so people with O blood type
possess antibodies against both A and B
antigens a against B antigens and B
against a antigens and if you are a so
you possess both A glycolipids and B
glycolipids you have neither
antibody so if we now go back to that
table I showed you at the start then it
becomes clear that liner had blood type
O when his blood cells were mixed with
anyone else's there was no utenation
however when his serum was added to
blood of others it could cause utenation
except in the case where it seems that
the person was also blood type O now it
is at this point we should really give a
round of applause to red blood cells
they may be small compared to other cell
types but they are Mighty by Mighty I
mean there are many of them an army of
red blood cells marching around our
vascular system system within our bodies
this Army includes 30 trillion red blood
cells in fact around a quarter of all
the human cells in our bodies are red
blood cells so we should for sure not
underestimate their
influence anyhow it got me thinking if
there are differences in sugars attached
to red blood cells given how many there
are within the body would there be a
fitness cost associated with being a
specific blood type well as usual it
turns out I was not the first to be
Curious by this
question researchers have looked at both
diseases and
Longevity however while I thought the
association would be linked to the uses
of sugar the relationship is due to the
structural changes of the sugar that
impact molecular
Communications let's
unpack firstly let's consider infectious
diseases typically these diseases like
viruses have to penetrate within a
healthy cell and to do that they need
some sort of molecular interaction it
could be a protein or it could be a
glycolipid this recent article found an
association with blood group a cells
showing them to be more likely to be
infected with sov 2 when compared with
blood group O
cells while these findings provide one
mechanism for how blood group a May
directly influence the risk of infection
with sarov 2 it does not mean that
people with blood group O have no need
to take precautions against
infection but while in this study it
showed that being blood type O was
protective against the infection by ssov
2 and in other studies against air
malaria it has been associated with
infection with
Novus fol and
ecoli so it seems like different fuses
have found alternative solutions to
invade different types of blood cell
types there has also been interesting
connection between blood type and cancer
for example O blood types have a lower
Hazard ratio to pancreatic
cancer from understanding how infectious
agents work it sort of made sense that
there could be an association with
infectivity however it is more
surprising to see studies showing a link
with cancer risk however it could be due
to the impact of these blood type
specific glycolipids on Cell adhesion
non o Bloods types have higher levels of
Fon willbrand Factor
a factor which plays a role in
hemostasis and blood
cloting and in corroboration with this
is the fact that O blood groups also
seem to have a lower risk compared to
non O blood types of developing coronary
artery
disease now age itself may be a
contributor to the vulnerability of
infectious diseases cancer and
cardiovascular disease so is there a
further correlation between the
blood groups and
Longevity well this table here
summarizes data from studies that that
have addressed this exact question they
differ depending on participant location
and
demographics sometimes there is an
association but other times there isn't
and in conclusion the issue of longevity
is particularly challenging according to
the current knowledge the biological
explanation is seemingly multifactorial
being the result of several inherited
such as the Alo and environmental
factors that interplay to cope with the
aging
process now whether or not there is a
benefit of being a certain blood group
type there is interest in inhibiting the
enzymes that add the sugars to make a
and b antigens to effectively turn all
blood cells to ootype since all you need
to really do is remove a sugar this is
desirable as O blood can be given
universally however at least from a
health perspective it is unclear if
being one type or another influences a
in at the
moment this is because it is ultimately
unclear what these glco lipids do and
it's worth reinstating that the
system is not the only difference that
distinguishes blood groups indeed there
are over 30 different substances now
both proteins and sugars that seem to
contribute to an individual's blood
group plus these glycolipids are not
just restricted to red blood cells but
they can also be found in other tissue
types such as Sensory neurons platelets
and the endothelia of the blood vessels
so while this investigation does not
appear to account for much these genetic
differences should not be simply
overlooked so with that blood shell I
hope you've learned something in this
video thank you to my Patron supporters
and thank you for
listening